we will look at just one interesting
Concept in this video and that is a coin
toss you will not believe how
interesting it is think about it when
you toss a coin it will either land a
head or a tail either head or tail all
of us would agree that these are the
only two
possibilities suppose I ask you a simple
question what is the probability of the
coin Landing ahead
this question asks us that if we toss a
coin what is the likelihood that the
coin lands a head how do we calculate it
here's how there is only one way in
which you can get AE the only way is if
it lands a head that's the first thing
we had to find out to find this
probability the second thing we need to
find out is the total number of
possibilities in total there are only
two possibilities a head or a tail this
number in the denominator is actually
all
possibilities these two cover all the
possibilities since you cannot possibly
get any other outcome you either get a
head or a tail this tells you that out
of the two possibilities there is only
one way in which this event can occur so
the probability of a coin Landing ahead
is 1 by two which is
1/2 this is a fraction and can also be
written in decimal form as 0.5
the numerator tells you the number of
ways in which an event can occur and the
denominator is all possible events
here's another question what is the
probability of a coin Landing a tail the
logic is very similar there is only one
way in which we can get a tail and the
total possibilities are just two head or
tail so the probability of getting a
tail is also
1/2 look at these two events land
Landing a head and Landing a tail both
have the same
probability and since the probability
tells us the likelihood of an event
occurring such events are called equally
likely events we say that getting aead
or getting a tail at the toss of a coin
are equally likely events that's because
their probability of occurrence is the
same let's try and deduce a formula for
the probability of an event in the numer
at we have the number of ways in which
an event can occur and in the
denominator we have the total number of
possible outcomes it just means how many
possibilities out of the total
possibilities this formula will be a lot
clearer as we see more and more examples
the formula is not important what's
important is what we are going to see
next what if there are 10 throws of a
single coin I'm I'm not talking about 10
coins tossed
simultaneously I'm talking about one
coin being tossed 10 times since the
events are equally likely does that mean
that after 10 throws we will surely get
five heads and five
tails this will not always be true you
may get six heads and four tails or
maybe nine heads and a tail or maybe
even 10 tals so what does this half
essentially tell us it tells us that but
if the process of tossing a coin is
repeated many many many times then we
will get approximately the same number
of heads and tails so if you toss a Fair
coin a million times you will see that
you would get almost the same number of
heads and tails remember the probability
does not give you a perfect or a
showshot answer it just tells you the
likelihood of an event
[Music]
occurring